hey guys Pete here this is my watzmann
episode six trailer breakdown episode
six will air on HBO the Sunday with the
title this extraordinary being the
episode description reads deep under the
influence of nostalgia angela gets a
first-hand account of her grandfather's
journey I'm gonna go through this
episode 6 trailer scene-by-scene
we're officially in the back half of
season 1 of HBO's Watchmen and this
video will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened in the series
so far things that have popped up in
other trailers and of course the source
material after the scene-by-scene
breakdown I will talk about some
theories and clues about future episodes
and I'll give you a second spoiler
warning if you want to avoid those the
tagline for an in-universe
pharmaceutical reads the present is a
worrisome time because the future is
unknown that leaves only the past to
comfort us The Watchmen episode six
official promo opens with Angela a bar
aka sister night in a jail cell in Tulsa
Oklahoma special agent Laurie Blake says
Angela you're not supposed to take
someone else's nostalgia that's very bad
in the first couple of shots we see of
Angela it does in fact look bad we can
tell she is starting to feel the effects
of taking her grandfather wills bottle
of pills which she learned were
nostalgia from looking glass right
before she was arrested at the end of
the last episode if you haven't been
reading the Supplemental materials or
didn't watch my episode 5 recap then
you're probably wondering what that
means the tagline I mentioned before is
from nostalgia marketing materials which
go on to say nostalgia by true is a
revolutionary
all-natural personally customized
medication for people suffering from
anxiety dementia and psychic trauma
nostalgia turns memories of your choice
into easily digestible tablets that
allow you to experience those memories
in the most lucid way possible
nostalgia is produced through a
treatment of neuro chemical scanning at
a licensed true clinic the procedure is
safe quick and painless so when we see
Laurie holding up a consent for
emergency treatment form as she says is
it starting
we know that Angela is getting ready to
go on a ride experiencing wills memories
we have a visual to guide us in a
character who is portrayed in
black-and-white and he's playing a drum
in her cell Laurie is worried about a
couple of things first we know that
nostalgia has been taken off the market
because it can cause psychosis
looking-glasses ex told us that the
second thing comes straight from the
nostalgia pamphlet again it says
ingesting nostalgia made for another
individual erodes the boundary between
self and other and catalyzes hyperactive
empathy or extreme fight/flight
responses it goes on to include an
impressive list of things that you would
never want to have happen to you as
possible side effects of taking someone
else's pills there's a lot to talk about
here with this medication so I'll come
back to it after we finish the scene by
scene what we see next is a trip back in
time complete with black and white
footage to mark that it's different we
visit a club where we see Angela's
grandparents having a conversation she
says to him you're an angry man William
Reeves as it cuts from Grandma to will
who looks like the actor who played
Michael and the leftovers it changes to
Angela and she says I'm not angry and
this gives us a pretty good idea of how
Angela's experiencing these memories
sometimes she sees well sometimes she is
well it all looks somewhat confusing
from there we go back a little bit
further to the 1921 race Massacre in
Tulsa where we see a young Will and his
father's arms Cowell makes an appearance
and it looks like he's in the jail in
the present day trying to get Angela to
snap out of it
he says you are Angela a bar I'm your
husband Calvin you have three children
while he's talking we see Angela as a
beat cop and that ties in to Lori
telling her that will was a cop in New
York back in the day what stands out
about this shot is that it looks like
she's holding a comic book that she
hands to the other man we can't see it
clearly but it looks like there's a big
a on the cover of it in the title which
makes me think about Action Comics and
Superman that feels like a nod to Hollis
Mason's origin story from under the hood
he talks about being obsessed with
reading Superman and not wanting to be
seen as an adult reading it there's also
been a lot of comparisons the Superman's
origin story thrown around with plenty
of references throughout this show that
brings Superman to mind so that's all
something
to think about we see her pass through a
doorway and we see her shift back to the
character of will again so it's just
another reminder that things are hazy in
these memories from there we get a shot
of her grandmother playing the piano as
we'll walks down the street in his
uniform this looks like two different
memories matched together as her
grandmother is in color and she's
playing the piano out on the sidewalk
which is out of place after that we see
bass Reeves pull off his hood and we
hear a couple of voices say trust in the
law it's noticeable that one of the
voices is a young William in the Tulsa
flashback in Episode one we learned that
he was a big bass Reeves fan and here we
see his hero show his badge Reeves as
the name that we'll uses so it's assumed
that he took his name from bass after he
left Tulsa that cuts to a memory of
Chief Judd Crawford saying you don't
know what's really happening here it's
interesting to have Judd pop up in wills
memories because that would make it more
likely that will was actually the person
who killed him
but we can't be sure if some of Angela's
own memories aren't mixed into what
we're seeing here and there are shots of
her sort of struggling mixed in with the
shot of the blood dripping onto the
badge that make things even less clear
the only thing that is clear is that
chief Judd will make one more appearance
at least in the series after a shot of
Angela closing her eyes we get a couple
of images that flash on the screen
there's a flash of light another shot of
the drum which we hear playing like a
drumroll in the background a flash in
color that looks like a symbol of an i
overlaid on crosshairs it's mysterious
because the symbol almost looks like
it's floating in the sky as it flashes
on and off of the screen the next image
also in color is of a gloved hand
holding a book the title says mesmerism
for the masses by WC florentine a quick
search let me know that mesmerism was a
technique that was used in the 19th
century to more or less balance a
person's invisible energy field a man
named Franz Mesmer created the technique
and there is a rabbit hole here if
you're willing to go down it the quick
and easy explanation is that Mesmer was
a bit of a showman he probably believed
what he was doing was helpful for people
and what he did was something that
sounds like a version of chakra balance
based on what he called animal magnetism
some people describe the technique as
being similar to hypnotism it's worth
noting that the scientific community
thought he was a charlatan after that we
see a different book or a folder with a
similar eye symbol on the cover it looks
like there are article clippings inside
but I couldn't make anything out except
for the letters lly at the end of a
headline at the top the same gloved
hands closed the book and we get a few
more flashes of both eye symbols as Cal
says Angela you need to come home you
need to wake up the symbols with the eye
are intriguing they're not exactly the
same but they look related it's possible
that one is an early version and the
other is an evolution they also look
related to the 7th cavalry symbol that
we saw painted around the hideout or
Looking Glass met with Keane those have
the dr. Manhattan symbol around the eye
but again could be an evolution not the
same but probably related it should be
wills memories we're seeing so is this
evidence that he has a connection to the
cavalry or was he investigating them and
something he found led to him killing
Crawford no way to tell for sure here
but it should be important when we find
out we have a close-up of Angela's face
eyes open as he says you need to wake up
and the promo ends there she's sitting
in the wheelchair under the tree here so
it looks like we'll find out what
happened on the night chief Judd was
killed in this episode this episode
looks like a ride and I'm down for that
if you're a fan of the leftovers you're
probably catching some international
assassin vibes here I know I am there's
quite a lot to think about in this
trailer but the focus seems to be
entirely on Angela and her grandfather
William Reeves in the interview that
came out this week where Lindelof
explained that fight was on Europa he
also mentioned that the character
doesn't appear in one of the episodes at
all after watching this I'm guessing we
might not be getting any Jeremy Irons
this week seeing Angela as will holding
what looks like a comic is important it
feels important anyways it has such a
strong connection to Hollis Mason story
and under the hood that I'm starting to
wonder how these two New York City cops
were connected the title of the episode
this extraordinary being comes from
the hood when Hollis is describing the
incident that we saw from American Hero
story where hooded justice busting
through the window to the market that's
where he got his name so it's clear that
he was influenced by him but the fact
that they're both cops I mean it just
seems like they may have been connected
that has something to do with why the
description that he used and under the
hood of who he thought it was might be
misdirection with that I'm gonna jump
into theories and speculation which may
contain light spoilers based on your
tolerance now's the time to click away
if you're worried about that kind of
thing but please give this video a like
and hit the subscribe button before you
go as soon as we'll Reeve showed up in a
trailer people theorized that he was
hooded justice the first trailer
breakdown I made which no one watched or
commented on had a few comments about it
having read the comic and especially
enjoying the supplemental stuff I've
been slow to jump on this bandwagon
because of the obvious problem of hooded
justice looking like a white man in
every image to be seen of him I
understand that this is explained in
those theories by him using white face
using paint and how there's a parallel
with Angela painting her face the theory
just didn't have enough to grab me I
favored the theories where will inspired
the original hood of Justice much in the
way that it's believed bass Reeves may
have inspired the Lone Ranger that was
further along when I saw a post on
Reddit from the original ideas from the
Minuteman where they show a character
named brother Knight he's not a
character that made it into the story
but come on his name's brother Knight
it's in the ultimate Watchmen so people
own this book and they've seen this
image and Angela's name is sister night
so I had been leaning very much in that
direction as the series has progressed
it seems more and more likely that they
are going to drop hooded justice being
will and the history of it being
whitewashed but either way we should
find out in this episode if will is
hooded justice or at least how he was
connected to the Minutemen in his
original letter to fans about making
Watchmen Lindelof said we also intend to
revisit the past century of costumed
adventuring through a surprising yet
familiar set of eyes and it's here we'll
be taking
greatest risk in an Entertainment Weekly
interview where he was asked about this
he said by the end of the sixth episode
it'll be clear who I was talking about
there won't be any space for debate I
think people will start to theorize who
I was talking about prior to the sixth
episode but that's the one that makes
the subtext text so count me in for this
reveal and I know I said this episode
looks like it would focus entirely on
Angela and will there is a shot of
American hero story Minutemen in the
episode six promotional photos that HBO
put out its hooded justice being Tara
gated at a police station so I imagine
someone will be watching the show in the
episode and that could play a part in
the reveal the fact that nostalgia was
created by lady true means that she
knows what it does she also knows will
left his behind for Angela defined and
doesn't seem all that worried about it
it makes you wonder what is in those
particular memories that they want
Angela to discover there is no lady
truth sightings in this trailer but with
her story and Williams being so
connected at this point we may get a
better idea what's going on popular
theories think that they may be trying
to create an empathy bomb or some kind
of empathy event where people will be
forced to feel the historical pains that
other people have experienced pretty
oversimplification of it but I think
you've probably already heard the theory
we know that she's giving something like
nostalgia to be in her daughter so these
pills may play a part and the reason I
brought the empathy thing up is because
it does stand out that one of the side
effects from taking somebody else's
memories or their nostalgia is that it
catalyzed this hyperactive empathy so
that is the big stuff in this trailer it
looks like a pretty exciting episode
like I said there's real international
assassin vibes here I can't wait
Ozymandias lady true and the rest of the
cast in Tulsa may be on the back burner
for this period of time but I think that
what we learn about will is going to be
game-changing not only for the current
story but for the history of costume
adventuring so I'm really excited let me
know in the comments what you're excited
about
what questions do you have about the
trailer or what questions do you have
about the season what
hoping to see what series do you like
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching I
will talk to you soon